i've been dreaming about this in my  whole life  and the giant's gold it's the biggest  treasure that's never been found  five billion easy  so when do we start yeah put that in  your head  hello hello  i can hear him sitting right next  your brother believed that there was a  final piece  but you know my brother sam what else  aren't you telling me  you have no idea who you partnered  it's with take a little longer than i  thought kids  i assume we're 50 50 right  50 50. you get 10 that's me being  generous wow  let's play some parachutes what  unless you know a better way to jump on  it  oh my god i'm so sorry  come on  500 years ago my family found the  vulture they were betrayed  so much blood  you're doing great  this ain't over  hey you still with me  barely  what's with the cat she's just real what  life seems super sad i'm not gonna keep  this thing exclusively in movie theaters  [Music]